Ockchamp, Wettke, ich müsste jetzt mal probieren ob ich es schaffe den ganzen Twitch-Stream
nur in Emotes zu sprechen. Wahrscheinlich. Das Schlimme ist, wahrscheinlich würde ich das
sprechen kriegen. Ja Leute, Twitch hat so nicht kapiert, dass der Stream,
und jetzt wartet mal, ich refresche mal kurz die Anzeige bei mir auf dem Vorschaumonitor. Moin. Die
Anzeige geht noch nicht. Ah, jetzt hat Twitch mitgekriegt. Angeblich sind es 0 Zuschauer,
was ja nicht sein kann Leute. Da sind quasi 3 durch 0. Gleich ist Twitch kaputt. Und wir sind
dran schuld. 4 durch 0, 5 durch 0. Schwierig. Oder wie sagt man da heutzutage zu belastend?
Oder ist es schon wieder aus? Ich glaube, das sagt man heute auch nicht mehr. Wo ist der Kabum?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wir haben eine Weile schon nicht mehr miteinander gesprochen. Ich
habe keine Ahnung. Ich vermute mal immer noch in Frankfurt irgendwo. Naja, übrigens heute. Heute
machen wir was ganz Tolles. Heute machen wir den Internetführerschein. Es gibt einen neuen
Internetführerschein. Aber ich warte jetzt erst mal bis der Stream richtig on ist. Das wird was,
ich sage es euch. Ja, das Bundesinnenministerium hat einen neuen Internetführerschein rausgebracht
und den machen wir heute. Hat 6 Kategorien in 3 verschiedenen Schwierigkeitsstufen. Nein,
er ist ergeblich wirklich ernst gemeint. Ich habe nur meine Zweifel, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ich weiß nicht, bin mir nicht so sicher. Tribulon, danke für den Sub. Take Viagra, die Hard. Danke
für den Sub. Huge Pog. Du bist zertifizierter Datenschutzbeauftragter. Huge Upgrade. Karriere
Pass Upgrade. Gut, ich hoffe du kriegst wenigstens jetzt da was. Ich hoffe es lohnt sich wenigstens.
Zumindest ist es schon mal nicht schlecht zu haben. Hast du denn auch den neuen Internetführerschein?
Wenn nicht, den machen wir heute Leute. Du hast auf der Seite 404, ernsthaft ist das schon wieder
kaputt? Probieren wir gleich aus, probieren wir gleich aus. Vorhin ging es noch. Vorher hat es noch
funktioniert. Das ist Haaresträumen teilweise, was da drin steht. Da steht drin Herr Stephanie
beauftragt sie. Da haben wir wie fünf Leute zusammen an einer Frage geschrieben. Ist ganz
grausam. Gut, vielleicht gibt es auch einen Herr Stephanie. Heutzutage kann man sowas ja nicht
mehr assuming. Dann ist ganz schnell der Spaß vorbei, wenn man sowas macht.
Bei nur der Schul und Arbeit habe ich schon ach so, na dann. Der Pog, der Internetführerschein,
der ist ganz wichtig ja. Soll ich euch mal was erzählen Leute? Oh nein, Avira will mir
mit der Premium aufschwätzen. Warum habe ich diesen Scheiß überhaupt noch auf dem zweiten
Rechner installiert? Das ist so useless. 10 Monate, danke für den Zapp. Was Cross Talk
Solutions hat heute UI Notify gelauncht. Äh, was, wie? Ist das G-Bait? Das ist doch Werbung,
oder? Das ist doch Werbung. Ist das Werbung? Sascha, ist das, ist das, ist das verpackte
Werbung? Es soll keine Werbung sein, es liest sich aber wie Werbung. Ja, Kommentare gelöscht
kann auf YouTube alles bedeuten. Da weiß man nicht so genau. Früher landeten die Kommentare
auf YouTube in so einem Bereich, wo man dann als Content Creator gesehen hat, dass Kommentare
geplockt wurden und man konnte die wieder freigeben. Aber mittlerweile landet die meistens,
das meiste Zeug gar nicht mehr da. Was ist der Kollege in der Firma, wurde jetzt Kaspersky
entfernt, weil ich aus Russland komme. Kappa HD, ja. Kommen die überhaupt aus Russland?
Waren die nicht irgendwie aus, irgendwie nur aus, warte mal, Kaspersky-Antivirus. Waren
die nicht irgendwie aus Litauen oder sowas oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander? Ja?
Okay, ne, dann bringe ich das durcheinander. Tatsächlich. Ne, die kommen wirklich nicht
aus Russland. Ich dachte, die kommen aus Litauen, mit was verwechsel ich die denn? Fällt euch
irgendetwas aus Litauen ein? Wahrscheinlich bin ich komplett neben der Spur. Moment, was?
In welchen Programmiersprachen ist das geschrieben? C++ und Nämmerle? Was zum Teufel ist Nämmerle
für eine Programmiersprache? Äh, das ist quasi ein Fake C-Sharp für.NET. Boah ne,
F-Sharp-Abklatsch. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das will ich mir gar nicht weiter angucken. In was
das alles programmiert ist? Nämmerle, habe ich schon nie gehört. Aber gut. Kaspersky
wird es schon wissen. Ja, ich wollte euch ja was als... Warum ist denn das jetzt da unten
rot? Ist das jetzt normal, wenn man streamt? Normalerweise früher war das immer nur rot,
wenn man recordet. Ich vermute mal, dass es jetzt auch rot ist, wenn man... Das hat mich
jetzt irritiert, will ich, dass meine Festplatte gleich voll ist, weil ich habe nicht mehr
so viel Platz. Es ist ein bisschen eng auf manchen meiner Laufwerke. Also hier ist es
ein bisschen eng. Da ist es ein bisschen eng. Da ist Platz, aber da ist... Weiß nicht so
genau. Mir war so... Ich wusste es. Ich wollte es nicht sagen. Ich wusste, als ich es ausgesprochen
habe, wusste ich, dass irgendjemand schreibt, entweder ein bisschen eng, Gachi Bass oder
eng ist gut. Irgendwie sowas. Es war mir jetzt so klar. Ich kenne den Chat mittlerweile. Ich
weiß halt schon Bescheid, was da los ist. Manchmal ist mir es schon klar, während ich was ausspreche,
weiß ich, da kommt jetzt das und es ist immer... Meistens so. 99% der Fälle.
Hast noch 2TB auf einer Platte frei. Soll ich dir meine 1TB Platte schicken, die ich bei
meiner letzten Kiste aus Versehen mitgeordert habe? Seagate Barracuda 1TB. Wobei, das Versandkosten
sind teurer, als die Festplatte in Prime bei Amazon zu bestellen. Ah, der Preischamp. Der
Preischamp ist offline. Der Preischamp, den gibt es nicht mehr. Den Preischamp, da solltest
du eigentlich noch nicht mal einen 404 kriegen. Beim Preischamp solltest du eigentlich... Ach
so, ich habe Cloudflare noch nicht gelöscht. Deswegen gibt es den 404. Oder habe ich Cloudflare
schon gelöscht? Sehen wir gleich. Bilde mir eigentlich ein, ich habe alles schon gelöscht,
aber habe ich Cloudflare vielleicht nicht gelöscht. Na gut. Soll ich euch mal was erzählen? Übrigens,
ich zeige euch erstmal, was wir heute machen. Der Defu. Digital. Ne, ne. Ne, ne, ne. Wie
hießen die? Defu. Doch, der Defu. Ach, sie haben sogar eine... Guck mal. Defu.de haben
die sogar. Eine Umlautdomain. Hier. Eine Emoji-Domain. Also mit diesen Escapes kann
man auch Emoji-Domains machen. Guckt euch das mal an. So. Das machen wir gleich. Das
machen wir gleich. Aber vorher muss ich euch noch was erzählen. Könnt ihr euch noch dran
erinnern? Ihr habt mich sogar letzten Sonntag danach gefragt. Könnt ihr euch noch dran
erinnern, als ich euch erzählt habe, ich musste letzten Montag was präsentieren auf der Arbeit.
Wobei, was heißt ich musste? Ich habe das sogar freiwillig gesagt. Ich mach das. Und
ich muss was präsentieren. Und ich habe euch ja auch erzählt, ich werde mich wahrscheinlich
nicht sonderlich beliebt dabei machen. Könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich noch dran erinnern,
weil es haben mich sogar am Sonntag viele gefragt. So, und Max, wie lief es denn? Und
am Sonntag habe ich noch gesagt, jawoll, lief wunderbar. Und heute, Leute, ich sag euch,
wir wurden heute, ich hab das ja mit einem Kollegen zusammen gemacht, alter Patrick,
35 Monate Hyper-Subscription, jetzt geht's ab. Richtig, Pog, dankeschön. So, wo bin
ich stehen geblieben? Genau, und heute, und heute, wir wurden übertrieben gelobt. Das
erlebt man bei mir auf der Arbeit selten, ja. Wir wurden übertrieben gelobt, wie toll
das war, dass wir das präsentiert haben. Und es hat manchen Leuten die Augen geöffnet.
Und da habe ich mir auch schon gedacht, easy clap. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was
eigentlich, was wir eigentlich gemacht haben? Wir haben eine halbe Stunde eigentlich durchgängig
erzählt, wie kacke so eine gewisse Sache ist bei uns. Aber anscheinend musste das mal
sein. Was hast du präsentiert? Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie ich das am besten überschreibe.
Ich habe über die Probleme beim Remote-Arbeiten berichtet und wie bei uns Sicherheit und Bedienbarkeit
in Konflikt steht. Ich glaube, so kann man das ganz gut beschreiben. Weil es wird immer
abge... Leute, ich erzähle euch was. Pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Eine absolut abgedrehte
Ausgeburt der Hölle, die sie sich jetzt überlegt haben bei uns auf der Arbeit. Also, damit du
bei uns auf wichtige Systeme kommst, Remote, wenn du Homeoffice machst oder sowas, kannst
du nicht einfach nur dich irgendwie connecten oder kommst du überall hin. Nein, das ist
ein bisschen komplizierter gemacht, was ja prinzipiell auch kein Problem ist. Du verbindest
dich per Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung auf ein Portal. In diesem Portal... Ja, ich habe
mir das schon gleich aufgeschrieben in meinem Dokument. So, in diesem Portal machst du
dann eine Shitrix-VM auf und von dort kannst du dich dann connecten. Da ist auch ein bisschen
mehr drumherum, aber ich will jetzt nicht alles genau erzählen. So, das war schon in der Vergangenheit
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig. Aber das war insofern okay, weil man das meistens wirklich
nur für Admin... Also, für Live-Administrationszeug... Es ist mega clunky und laggy as fuck. Für
Admin-Administrationszeug gebraucht hat und Wolle, danke schön für den Sub. Und deswegen
es ging. Man konnte sich dann auch irgendwie tunneln, auch wenn es nur so Grauzone war,
ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist. So, aber jetzt haben sie den Vogel abgeschossen. Die ganze
Zeit war das so, für Datenaustausch konnte man entweder VPN verwenden, also was weiß
ich, wenn ich irgendwelche größeren Sachen irgendwie rumkopieren muss. Sei es, dass die
Sekretärin irgendeine 50 MB Excel-Datei kopieren muss oder dass man Logs mal rumkopieren muss
oder so. Also, für Datenaustausch hatte man Folgendes. Entweder VPN oder man konnte das
Notebook aus der Firma mitnehmen oder sich so geheim schicken lassen, wenn man da Homeoffice
hat. Oder man hatte eine normale Office-VM, auch über Shitrix. So, und da gab es dann
ein gemeinsames Windows-Share für seinen User. Und die Musik ist ein bisschen lauter. Außerdem
ist die Musik äußerst nervös. So. Die ist mir immer noch zu nervös. Die mag zwar
happy sein, ja, viel besser. So. Und dann haben sie sich... Irgendwie ist die Musik
jetzt zu nervig gerade. Okay. Gut. Wunderbar. Also, wo bin ich stehen geblieben? Ja, also
du konntest das Datenaustausch noch halbwegs normal machen. Du hattest so einen Windows-Share
für deinen User und da konntest du Zeug drüber kopieren. Das war auch relativ schnell. Ist
alles okay gewesen. So. Und jetzt kommt der Hammer. Das war so auch mit der Steine des
Anstoßes. Als ich gesagt habe, jetzt reicht es, kann ich nicht mehr arbeiten. Ich kann
mich auch gerne hinsetzen, ohne was zu machen und ihr gebt mir Geld. Aber das kann so nicht
sein. Man hat sich jetzt Folgendes überlegt. Jetzt haltet euch fest. Wir ersetzen, also
sie ersetzen den Windows-Share durch OneDrive. So. Und jetzt erzähle ich euch mal ein wirklich
praktisch so passiertes Anwendungsszenario. Ein Kollege von mir, das habe ich euch ja
schon mal vor einer Weile erzählt, dass wir in der Richtung was gemacht haben, hat, hat,
hat, ja ja OneDrive, OneDrive. Ein Kollege von mir hat Hilfe gebraucht bei Log-Auswertung.
Der hatte glaube ich irgendwie zwei Terabyte Squid-Logs. Und die Squid-Logs sollten durchsucht
werden, ob irgendwelche speziellen Aufrufe drin sind, um daraus ableiten zu können,
ob Firewall-Regeln noch gebraucht werden. Ist egal warum. So. Zumindest Squid-Logs durchsuchen.
Also was haben wir gemacht? Haben wir gesagt, hey das haben wir doch schon mal gemacht. Ich
hatte nämlich, er hatte das damals in Bash programmiert. Und ohne Scheiß, Bash hat eine
Woche die Squid-Logs durchsucht. Eine Woche Leute. Eine Woche. So. Danach sind wir hingegangen,
haben ein.NET Programm gebastelt. Multithreaded 24 Kerne auf einer richtig fetten Kiste. Multithreaded
24 Kerne. Das meiste auch noch irgendwie 128 Gigabyte RAM. Das meiste eben RAM gehalten
mit einem Dictionary gedifft, gemacht, geguckt, gezählt, gecounted. Am Ende lief es irgendwie
40 Minuten oder so versus eine Stunde. Also 40 Minuten Programm in C-Sharp Multithreaded
versus eine Woche in Bash. Das kann durchaus sein. Bash ist nicht sonderlich effektiv.
Vor allem wenn man das auch noch ein bisschen umständlich macht. So. Und das war, das war
der Plan. Wir haben gesagt, weißt was, haben wir doch schon mal gemacht. Wir nehmen einfach
dieses Programm und passen das, passen das an für den neuen Anwendungsfall. So. Und jetzt
haltet euch fest. Jetzt, jetzt kommt's. Mein, mein Datenaustausch. Wie lange habt ihr daran
programmiert? Das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert. Zwei, drei Stunden. Das war nicht, ist kein
großer Akt gewesen. Zumindest. Dadurch, dass ich jetzt keinen Share mehr habe, den ich
irgendwie von einem Notebook verwenden kann, von einer VM verwenden kann, von einer Administrationskiste
verwenden kann. Ich hab keinen Windows Share. Also ich hab keinen Share mehr. Musste ich
jetzt folgendes machen. Als erstes musste ich mir eine Beispiel-Log-Datei ziehen. Das
ging nicht. Weil der Virenscanner gesagt hat, die Datei ist größer als 30 MB, wird abgebrochen.
Ist bestimmt Ransomware. So. Also Testlogs ziehen hat schon mal nicht funktioniert. Okay.
Aber jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der absolute Hit. Jetzt kommt der absolute
Hit. Ich hab dann, weil ich es ums Verrecken nicht machen konnte, mit der, mit der VM,
die mir die Firma zur Verfügung stellt, hab ich lokal bei mir eine Ubuntu VM gebootet,
mit Rider und allem, was ich an Entwicklung brauche für.NET Programme, hab mir ein Log-Auszug
kopiert, 10 MB, und hab das angepasst, das Programm. So. Also allein schon, dass ich
das auf einer privaten VM machen muss, ist halt absolut lächerlich, dass die Firma das
dann auf die Reihe kriegt. So. Und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt wirklich
der Hit. Das war, ich war fertig, hab's kompiliert, und wir wissen ja, sobald's kompiliert, funktioniert
das auch, und jetzt war die Frage, wie kriege ich dieses Programm denn auf die fette 24
Kerne Kiste drauf, wo die Logs draufliegen zum Auswerten. Ich hatte keinen gemeinsamen
Share mehr, und ich hab allen Ernstes, jetzt, kein Witz, ich musste mich lokal auf meiner
Ubuntu VM in meinem OneDrive einloggen, das Programm dort hochladen, dann musste ich
mich über eine Shitrix-Administrations-VM verbinden, dort das Programm runterladen
von OneDrive, dann per SCP auf den Produktionsjump-Host kopieren, von dort auf den Server kopieren,
und dann starten, und dann feststellen, und dann feststellen, dass ich was vergessen hab,
und wieder von vorne. Ohne Scheiß, das hat zwei Stunden gedauert, für fünfmal kompiliert
und dann so. Das war der absolute Over-Up-Fuck. Einziger Workflow, ja, richtig geil, das ist
so der übende, richtig krasser Business-Enterprise-Workflow, ne? Musst du dich auch mit Microsoft Access
nein, zum Glück nicht. Richtiger Lean-Up, safe, safe und lean ist der, ja. ITIL zertifiziert
auch noch, DIN ISO 9001, alles auf einmal. So, und ganz ehrlich, da war der Punkt erreicht,
wo ich gesagt, Leute, ich kann so nicht arbeiten, also erst will ich so nicht arbeiten, ich kann
auch so nicht arbeiten, und das müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen an die größere Glocke
hängen. Und deswegen haben wir das letzte Woche vorgestellt auf einer abteilungsübergreifenden
Security-Runde, da waren alle möglichen Abteilungsleiter da, und die sind der letzten Montag da irgendwie
aus allen Wolken gefallen. Und heute hat uns dann jemand erzählt, dass das halt eben eine
ganz tolle, augenöffnende Präsentation war. Was im Endeffekt heißt, ihnen war gar nicht
klar, wie beschissen das ist, was sie da gebaut haben. Oh man, die, aber muss ich sagen, also
entweder ist das die Standard-Taktik, so nach dem Motto, boah habt ihr gut gemacht, wir
schmeißen euch jetzt raus, oder die fanden das wirklich gut. Kann ja sein, ja. Zumindest
scheint ihnen klar zu sein, aber ich hab auch wirklich, ich hab, wir haben denen auch wirklich
alles, alles aufs Brot geschmiert. Also die Präsentation lief ungefähr so ab, also ganz,
ganz grob, wir haben gesagt, ja hallo hier Max, und hallo hier Dings, mit dem ich das
gemacht hab, die meisten kennen uns ja, aber wir sind jetzt auch mal hier am Start, und
heute müssen wir ein bisschen meckern, und das und das und das kommt heute. Und dann
hab ich gleich mit dem richtigen Knaller gestartet, ich hab einen Screenshot gemacht, als meine
Administrations-VM das letzte Mal zu wenig RAM hatte und mein Browser gecrasht ist, hab
ich gleich gescreenshotted, ich hab sogar extra ein GIF danach noch gemacht, von den
Dingern, die abgekackt sind, da hab ich gesagt, so die Admin-VM, langsam, laggy, copy-paste
geht nicht, und manchmal verliert man seine Arbeit, weil es crasht. Und da konnten sich
auch irgendwelche Excel-Schubser relaten dazu und haben das verstanden. Das ist keine
gute Idee. Ja, und dann haben wir danach noch, danach hat mein Kollege übernommen, und
nein, die Präsentation hatte nur Emojis, keine Twitch-Emojis. So, zumindest, danach
hab ich gemeint, so ich übergebe jetzt mal kurz hier an meinen Kollege, ich sag jetzt
den Namen nicht, weil ich kann sagen, Tim heißt er, das ist ja nix, nix, nix, geheimes,
also ich übergebe jetzt an den Tim, und der erzählt jetzt noch mal die vielen Kleinigkeiten,
die an der Admin-VM nerven, da hat der Tim angefangen, und ohne Scheiß, vier Seiten,
vier Seiten, erster Punkt, zweiter Punkt, dritter Punkt, vierter Punkt, fünfter Punkt,
sechster Punkt, da hat er das auch so richtig durchgerannt, vier Seiten, einfach so in
fünf Minuten, bam, bam, bam, bam, mit Punkten drauf, die alle kacke sind, und danach hat
denen schon der Kopf geraucht, da haben wir gesagt, was, so viel ist da im Arsch, da bin
ich noch mal dran gekommen und hab noch mal, da hab ich das Beispiel gebracht mit dem OneDrive
kopieren, und noch ein anderes Beispiel, und ich glaube, spätestens dann war vorbei, ich
glaube, da hatten wir uns alle insofern überzeugt, dass das so wie es jetzt ist, absolut kacke
ist. So, und warum erzähl ich euch das Ganze jetzt, nicht nur weil wir irgendwie, nicht
nur weil sie uns super gelobt haben, was ich natürlich immer tolle finde, ja, kann ich
gleich, sag ich gleich was zu, nein, nein, noch viel besser, typische Business Enterprise
Move würde heute versucht, die haben uns erstmal, die haben uns total gelobt, haben
gesagt, oh, war ja richtig, hat die richtig Augen geöffnet in die Präsentation und sonst
was, hab ich schon gedacht, oh nein, freut mich, freut mich, und dann kam die Frage,
und jetzt haltet euch fest, das ist so die typische Business Enterprise Frage, dann
wollten sie uns fragen, so ja, ob wir denn dieses Thema jetzt auch weiter vorantreiben
können, da hab ich mir so gedacht, nee, das dürft ihr schon schön selber machen, ich
treib doch nicht, ich guck mal, ich schreib mir doch nicht dieses Drecks Thema auf die
Fahne, allen Ernstes, ob wir das Thema jetzt weiter vorantreiben, ich glaub, es geht los,
ja.
Das einzige, wozu wir uns haben breitschlagen lassen, ist, dass wir jetzt, dass wir jetzt
als Ansprechpartner uns bereitstellen, wenn es Updates für diese Administrations-VM gibt,
und ob wir, dass wir die dann testen, wenn es sie dann gibt, ja, aber ganz bestimmt treibe
ich jetzt diesen Mist nicht weiter voran, das ist überhaupt nicht, das ist erstens
über meiner Gehaltsklasse, das ist auch überhaupt nicht mein Ding, ich will damit auch nichts
zu tun haben, ich will es einfach nur benutzen, weil ich unterm Strich einfach nur arbeiten
will, ohne dass es mich die ganze Zeit abfuckt, ach, zu scheiße, naja gut, wie alt bist du,
ich bin 37, ja, 37, ich bin 1984 geboren, ja, aber jetzt was zu dieser Frage, bevor
wir dann den Internetführerschein machen, ja, das hat weder mit DevOps noch mit Entwicklung
noch mit sonst was zu tun, das ist Infrastruktur bereitstellen, das hat mit meinem Zeug überhaupt
nichts zu tun, zum Glück, ich hätte es überhaupt nichts, ich hätte mir garantiert keine Shit-Tricks-Geschichte
hingestellt zum Remote-Arbeiten, so, hier Radiosignal-Frag, habe ich das richtig verstanden,
du programmierst unter Linux mit C-Sharp, kompilierst und schiebst dann das Programm
auf dem Windows Server, nein, nein, nein, das sind Linux-Kisten, alles Linux, wir haben
zu 99% Linux bei uns, Red Hat, Red Hat-Kompatibel, sagen wir es mal so, gibt da nicht viel,
außer CentOS, was es sein könnte, ne, es gab mal, früher gab es Scientific und jetzt
gibt es Rocky, Rocky, ich weiß nicht, ob Rocky, irgendjemand schon Rocky Linux im Einsatz
hat, ne, Susie, Susie ist bäh, ne, Red Hat-Kompatibel bedeutet im Endeffekt nur, es ist quasi
ein Red Hat mit Red Hat-Logos entfernt, das sind die Red Hat-Sources neu kompiliert, ohne
die Copyrights-Sachen drin, ich habe nicht studiert, nein, ich habe mal 2007 fachinformatischer
Systemedikation gelernt, ne, ne, aber das sind alles Linux-Kisten bei uns, wir haben
ein paar Windows Server, aber da habe ich Gott sei Dank nichts mit zu tun, Wushild Studio
Code kann doch Remote Code Developen, über SSH würde das gehen, ne, nicht so einfach,
tja, möglich, könnte ich das vielleicht sein, ich mein, ich hab das gleiche Profilfoto,
ich höre mich genauso an, ich laber den gleichen Scheiß, ich würd sagen Exposed, oh man, ok,
Leute, ja und mein YouTube-Kanal ist auch verlinkt, so, das dachte ich mir, das muss
ich euch jetzt mal erzählen, jetzt gucken wir, jetzt machen wir den Digitalführerschein,
wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob die Seite im Darkreader besser aussieht, naja, zumindest
kriegt man nicht gleich Augenverbrennung, wenn man sich die Seite anschaut, so, also
das ist jetzt neu, das gibt es seit heute, kannst du dich noch an mich erinnern, wer
bist du denn auf YouTube, wahrscheinlich nicht, es gibt ein paar an, die kann ich mich erinnern,
oder es gibt ein paar Namen, wenn ich die sehe, kann ich mich dran erinnern, aber bei
fast 300.000 Abonnenten ist es schwierig, da jetzt im Detail jeden zu kennen, ist ja klar,
das ist echt, nein, das ist echt, es gibt jetzt wirklich seit heute, gibt es einen neuen
Internetführerschein, du dachtest, wir sind alle deine Freunde, ja ihr seid so, also wenn
ihr Primes habt, können wir darüber reden, aber genauso wie Bibi zufällig die Uhr, die
sie vorstellt, heute im Laden entdeckt hat und nicht dafür gesponsert wird.
Heißt er auf YouTube HelpfulGuy, einer deiner größten Fans damals, keine Ahnung, also das
ist schon so lange her, weiß ich nicht, sagt mir jetzt nichts, aber trotzdem schön, dass
du deine Wege hierher gefunden hast.
Cringe wenn ich seine Abonnenten kenne, sage ich dazu nur, ja also es war kein Memetitel,
ich mache heute wirklich den neuen Digitalführerschein, so und was das sein soll ist, das ist vom
Bundesinnenministerium ein neuer Online, wie nennen wir das, Fortbildungslernplattform
mit Tests, wo man dann angeblich, so schwebt es denen vor, ich habe da ja so meine Zweifel
wenn ich ehrlich bin, woran man dann auch für den beruflichen Weg, also quasi für
Jobsuche und sonst was, sein Digital und Internet Knowhow unter Beweis stellen kann, so das sagen
die, nachdem das nicht das erste ist in dieser Richtung und die letzten Versuche in dieser
Richtung ziemlich beschissen waren, um es mal klar zu sagen, habe ich meine Zweifel,
dass das was taugt, aber das gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal an.
Moritz danke für den Sub, Lukas danke auch dir für den Sub, 2 Monate Cute Subscription
hier, aber die sind modern, die sind modern, es ist Beta, es ist Beta, nicht Sigma, es
ist Beta, ob da der EU Kommissar, der Oettinger für Digitalisierung oder Digital, bestimmt
war da der Oettinger mit am Start, Deutschland sicher im Netz, so loslegen, wir gucken uns
es jetzt an, Bäm, also, zum DeFi-Lernangebot, wie möchtest du den DeFi nutzen, ok, was
ist der Unterschied, beruflicher Kontext, die Arbeitswelt bringt ihre ganz eigenen Herausforderungen
mit sich, unser Lernangebot im Beruf, die bietet ihnen Inhalte, die speziell darauf
zugestimmt, alles klar beruflicher Kontext, easy, Level 1, ne wir machen mal, wir machen
mal eine Sache, wir fangen mal an, warum alles so groß ist, weil mein Browser auf, wobei
der ist auch sonst relativ groß, wir fangen mal privat Level 1 an, nur mal so, just for
fun um ein bisschen zu kecken, was die, wie die Fragen so sind, so und dann gibt es dann
mehrere Kategorien mit jeweils 8 Fragen, Geräte, Internet, Kommunikation, Datenwelt,
Gefahrenschutz, Technologie Alltag, so und da kann man jetzt wohl irgendwie einen Test
machen, wir machen jetzt einen Test, jetzt müssen wir uns registrieren, POGChamp, N-Minute,
Mail, jawoll, UAS, E-Mail-Adresse, Zack, ich brauche noch kurz ein Passwort random generate,
Leute ich random generate jetzt ein Passwort, passt mal auf, exellent, boah das ist das
randomeste Passwort aller Zeiten, so, vollschönige Name, Geburtstag, wie Geburtstag noch, 1.1.1900,
ja genau, indem ich fortfache Stimmen in RGB registrieren, ja ja, ahja gut, wie, ich muss
ja nicht mal eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail machen, keine Bestätigungs-E-Mail, was ist denn mit
euch los, oh fuck jetzt habe ich zugemacht, wenn ich jetzt noch eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail
brauche bin ich, oh nein ich habe mein Passwort geleakt, shit jetzt könnt ihr euch alle bei
die für einloggen für mich, nein, ok ich mache einen neuen Account, so geht das dann
nicht, neuen Account, neuen Account, 10-minute-mail, wir machen jetzt einen neuen Account, 10-nut-mail,
nein, nein, nein, nein, 10-minute-mail.net, ok das ist jetzt neu, wobei scheiß drauf,
was hatte ich denn vorher, ist doch scheiß egal ob ihr das Passwort seht, ich habe sogar
meine E-Mail, Leute hat noch jemand die E-Mail Adresse von eben, ich kacke nur, ich habe
es zugemacht einfach, egal ich registriere mich jetzt neu, so registrieren, jetzt können
sie sich anmelden, nein, nein, nein, ich will mich neu registrieren, lass mich registrieren,
jawoll, neues Passwort, ok, so, ja, Geburtstag, 1.01.2019, ok registrieren, anmelden, E-Mail
Adresse, jawoll, da sind wir, Pock, was erwarte dich in der Diffi Prüfung, Leute ich glaube
ich muss euch Flashbangen, ah mal gucken, was erwarte dich, wann gilt meine Prüfung
als bestanden, moment, mindestens 50% der Fragen, was ist denn das für ein Müll, 50%,
das kriegst du ja schon mit simplem randomisen hin, normalerweise musst du bei sowas 80 haben
oder, oder sowas, oder maximal 2 falsch oder 50, das ist ja mies, ok, ich bin einverstanden,
gucken wir uns das mal, das ist jetzt wohlgemerkt, das ist für die oberkacknoobs privat, nur
zum warm werden, ja, also, was nutzen Smart Home Geräte nicht zur Datenübertragung, push,
was auch immer push in dem Kontext bedeuten soll, keine Ahnung, weiter, was würdest
du sagen, welche Maßnahmen tragen im Smart Home zur Sicherheit bei, regelmäßige Installation
von Updates ist gut, Passwort in der Steuerungs App ist auch gut, Sicherheitsindex einschalten,
was ist denn der Sicherheitsindex, hä, ok, ihr wisst es auch nicht, oder, ok, wir lassen
das einfach mal, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der Sicherheitsindex ist, schalte den Index
ein, ok, was musst du beachten, bevor du dir eine App auf dein Smart Home, äh, Smartphone
lädst, ok, Bewertung im Netz zur App lesen, bei schlechten Bewertung die App lieber nicht,
ja, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee, Kosten überprüfen nicht, alle Apps sind kostenlos,
ja, vor dem Laden Cookies prüfen, ich mein, kann man machen, aber wozu ergibt in diesem
Kontext wenig Sinn, ok, weiter, der Herr Demir hat eine Wetter App auf sein Smartphone heruntergeladen,
diese fordert die Berechtigung ein auf das Adressbuch, oh nein, die russischen Hacker
sind am Start, zuzugreifen, gekommenet, das ist die gehackte Wetter App, also, ähm, Leute,
ich muss mal kurz husten, es ist übrigens schon besser, danke für die Nachfrage, letztens
haben ganz viele sich dafür interessiert, ob alles wieder gut ist, husten, schon deutlich
besser, viel, viel besser, ok, also, Herr Demir hat eine Wetter App auf sein Smartphone heruntergeladen,
diese fordert die Berechtigung ein auf das Adressbuch im Smartphone zuzugreifen, sollte
er der App Bewertung die Berechtigung gewähren, nein, das braucht kein Adressbuch, aber mittlerweile
gehört es da zum guten Ton, dass du zig Berechtigungen anfragst, ja, Telefonberechtigungen, Standortlokalberechtigungen,
Adressbuchberechtigung, alle möglichen, du brauchst einfach Berechtigung, am Endeffekt
ist es irgendeine App, die Cookie-Clicker macht oder sowas, aber machen wir, machen wir,
machen wir, nein, die App braucht nur um das Wetter, ok, Drucker, was, ach, soll ich das
jetzt rüber tracken und droppen oder wie, so, boah, also, ich meine, meine Oma hätte
den Test wahrscheinlich auch hingekriegt, aber wer braucht schon eine Erklärung dafür,
ich meine, scheiß drauf, einfach, einfach oben hinschreiben, 5 von 8, das reicht, ok,
Tastatur, App, Vierenschutz, wobei man, wobei es da jetzt schon ein bisschen Grauzone sein
kann, Drucker, Monitor, App Store, Tablet, Betriebssystem, alles klar, next, in welchem
Store findest du Apps für das Betriebssystem iOS, welches auf iPhones installiert ist,
auf dem Microsoft Store, ganz ehrlich, im Microsoft Store findet man auch nicht mal
Dinger auf Betriebssystem, die, wofür der Microsoft Store gedacht ist, also der Microsoft
Store, den kannst du eigentlich immer streichen, so, App Store, wofür steht das W in WLAN,
Watt, Wide, Kabel und Wireless, Wire, Wire, das berühmte WLAN Kabel, jetzt wird's, jetzt
wird's etwa ein C8 von 8, Mo möchte ein Smart Home Grid kaufen, Mo, bestimmt die Abkürzung
für Moritz oder sowas, Mo, erinnert mich an die Diablo 2 Kühe, kann sich da noch einer
ausreden, Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo, es könnte auch Mohamed sein, richtig, muss nicht Moritz sein, man
weiß ja heutzutage nicht, so, und man weiß auch nicht, ob Mo er ist, es könnte ja auch
sie sein oder sonst was, Fahrräder und Helikopter, keine Ahnung, also Mo möchte ein Smart Home
Gerät kaufen, er ja nicht triggert sein Chat, nicht gleich wieder ausrasten, ja, zieht
es raus, direkt, so, Mo möchte ein Smart Home Gerät kaufen, leider sind die alle sehr teuer,
er hat eine viel günstige Kopie eines Geräts bei einem Hersteller aus China, die China-Chinesen,
da sind sie, die sollen genauso gut funktionieren wie das Original, soll er zuschlagen, ja,
soll er, ich meine, die wollen wahrscheinlich sagen, dass man das nicht sollte, aber ihr
kennt mich, also die richtige Antwort ist, also die Antwort, was die hören wollen ist
A, die richtige Antwort ist aber eigentlich B, jetzt könnte ich meinen AliExpress Affiliate
Code hier mal unter die Leute bringen, den ich nicht besitze, also gucken wir uns mal
die Antworten an, nein, Smart Home Geräte sollte man nur von seriösen Herstellern bei
vertrauenswürdigen Händlern kaufen, Kopien aus China haben leider oft Mängel in der Sicherheit
oder in der Qualität, also ich kann euch eins sagen, Smart Home Geräte, wenn man nicht
weiß, was die genau machen, beziehungsweise custom Firma vielleicht und sonst was, du
weißt nie, was die normalerweise, also was die machen und du weißt auch nie, ob die Sicherheitsmängel
haben, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass so ziemlich 90% dieser normalen Smart Home Dinger, die
du daheim hinstellst, haben Sicherheitsprobleme, ich möchte nur mal daran erinnern, die Leute,
die Wisecams hatten, da waren die Streams öffentlich über den China-Chinesen-Server
abrufbar und dazu kommt, selbst wenn ich mir jetzt hier bei Amazon.de ein Gerät von einem
deutschen Hersteller, nennen wir mal Hammer aus Bayern, Hammer, wenn du da von denen eine
Steckdosenleiste kaufst, das ist exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste wie von den China-Chinesen,
das weiß ich, weil ich mir absichtlich die Steckdosenleiste von Hammer gekauft habe,
weil es die baugleiche China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleiste ist, wo ich Custom Firmware draufflaschen
kann, nur, dass Hammer das glücklicherweise so gemacht hat, eine uralt Firmware drauf
zu machen, sodass sie noch flashbar war, so, also ja, er sollte zuschlagen, die Technik
ist ja die gleiche, also Leute, es ist alles genauso sicher, es ist davon überhaupt nichts
sicher, wenn du nicht selbst den Kram drauf machst, okay, wir nehmen die offizielle Antwort,
aber die eigentliche Antwort ist ja, Teilprüfung abschließend, bam, easy, huge, easy, way to
dank, genau, so, wir machen noch eine weitere für die Noobs, was kommt nämlich als nächstes,
wir machen noch Internet für Noobs, Leute, den Rest machen wir dann für Profis, ja,
aber das Internet für Noobs, das müssen wir noch machen, wir machen noch mal das Internet
für Noobs und dann machen wir beruflich Level 3, bam, also starten, jawoll, was bedeutet
privater oder anonymer Modus im Browser, das hängt ein bisschen vom Browser-Hersteller
ab, okay, ist dieser aktiviert, werden die Webseiten, die ich mir angesehen habe, nicht
in einer Liste gespeichert, das wollen sie wahrscheinlich hören, wobei das so nicht ganz
richtig ist, zum Beispiel hast du im privaten Modus Safari IOS, hast du einen extra Private
Tab und solange du den nicht schließt, hast du eine Übersicht der geöffneten Seiten und
sowas in der Richtung, also das wollen sie wahrscheinlich hören, ist aber nicht ganz
richtig, ist dieser aktiviert, werden im Browser keine Passwörter gespeichert, die ich auf
Webseiten eingebe, es werden normalerweise eh keine Passwörter gespeichert, die ich
auf Webseiten eingebe, außer ich sage explizit, ist dieser aktiviert, werden meine Webcam
abgeschaltet, schaltet der private Modus die Webcam ab, nee, oder, ist dieser aktiviert
mit meiner IP Adresse geändert, also die Nummer, mit der sich meine Geräte im Internet identifizieren
und über die HackerInnen, das ist ganz wichtig an der Stelle, auf mein PC zugreifen können,
es hängt vom Browser Hersteller ab, normalerweise nicht, aber wenn du sowas wie Opera verwendest
mit China-Chinesen VPN, die haben ja so Funktionen drin, also ich würde es jetzt mal so lassen,
mal gucken, ob die damit einverstanden sind, was ist kein Browser, Exploration, Safari,
Chrome, Firefox, Exploration, Herr Müller akzeptiert immer alle Cookies, wenn er eine
Webseite besucht, welche Konsequenzen hat das, wahrscheinlich gar keine, wenn man ehrlich
ist, es passiert nichts weiter, wenn der Anbieter, was denn der Anbieter erfährt nicht, auf
welchen Unterseiten Herr Müller sich wie lange aufgehalten hat, was, äh, also, du hast
schon die Möglichkeit zu tracken, prinzipiell über irgendwelche JavaScript-Geschichten,
wie lange einer sich eine Seite anguckt, aber, hä, das habe ich Cookies überhaupt nichts
zu tun, ist die Webseite ein Online-Shop und hat er Waren in seinen Warenkorb gelegt, kann
er die Bestellung auch einen Tag später abschicken, wenn sein Warenkorb wird beim zweiten Besuch
wieder hergestellt, ja, das kann man mit Cookies machen, das geht, das kann man mit Cookies
machen, das, das geht mit Cookies, das geht aber auch noch anders, aber mit Cookies geht
das auch, Herr Müller bekommt auf verschiedenen Websites, zum Beispiel im Suchmaschinen immer
wieder Werbung angezeigt, die ja zu seiner letzten Bestellung im Online-Shop passen, ja,
das muss auch nicht zwangsläufig über Cookies gemacht sein, aber wahrscheinlich oder wie
auch immer, yes, yes, also, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal so, äh, das mit den Unterseiten,
keine Ahnung, die sind sehr vage, das erinnert mich an die Leute, ich muss mein Headset mal
kurz entknoten, äh, das hat Aussetzer, das sackt, so, ich bin wieder da, ok, wir lassen
es jetzt einfach so weiter, was ist keine Suchmaschine, ah, Firefox, jetzt hätten sie
mich fast gebaited, fast, fast wäre der gebaited raus gewesen, äh, was kannst du mit deinem
Browser machen, Dateien und Ordner auf deiner Festplatte sortieren, im WWW auf Webseiten
surfen, ja, das auf jeden Fall, dein Rechner auf Virenbefall prüfen, ja, aber das wollen
sie wahrscheinlich nicht hören, ich sag mal Virus total oder sowas, also, ja, du kannst
mit deinem Browser auch Rechner auf Virenbefall prüfen, aber das wollen sie wahrscheinlich
nicht hören an der Stelle, den Verlauf deiner besuchten Webseiten löschen, ja, das kann
ich auch mit einem Browser machen, wobei das eher nicht so der Hauptanwendungszweck eines
Browsers ist, weiter, äh, wo kannst du bei deinem Smartphone zwischen WLAN und mobile
Internet umschalten, ja, das kommt, das hängt vom Smartphone ab, ok, wahrscheinlich das
hier, wahrscheinlich, aber das hängt ganz entscheidend vom Smartphone ab, das kannst
du so, so, ähm, universell nicht sagen, sollte den Hersteller mal rausbringen, ein Gerät,
was Knöpfe dafür hat, dann geht das damit, also, das ist so allgemeingültig, kann man
das überhaupt nicht sagen, weiter, welche Unternehmen betreiben Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland,
Telekom, Vodafone, ja, 1&1, GMX und Kongstar, nee, Kongstar ist Telekom, Saturn, Media Markt
und Cyberport, nee, das ist Telekom, Vodafone, O2, was ist mit Web, Web 2.0, Leute, Web 2.0
ist doch schon wieder, also, das ist komplett, komplett outdated, alter, Web 2.0, wir sind,
wir sind Web 4.0, Industrie 8.0, agile, horizontal, diagonalskalierer, serverless, Web, NFT,
was auch immer, aber 2.0, also, das Internet ist größer geworden, sodass nun mehr Inhalte
hineinpassen, alles klar, das Internet ist mit einem Update aktualisiert worden, sodass
es nun sicherer ist, jeder Mensch kann im Internet Inhalte veröffentlichen, was, was, was wollt
ihr von mir wissen, das letzte, oder, wahrscheinlich C, wahrscheinlich C, Leute, mein Headset hat
immer noch Aussetzer, wartet mal kurz, ich muss es mal kurz fixen und ich muss euch muten,
weil ansonsten fliegen euch die Ohren weg, so, ich hoffe, ihr findet alles, ihr könnt
wahrscheinlich wieder das wissen, okay, Teilprüfung abschließen und, was haben wir richtig, Leute,
wir haben Frage 1 verkackt, Frage 1, fail, was bedeutet private oder, okay, ja, meinetwegen,
wie gesagt, normalerweise werden die Passwörter eh nur gespeichert, wenn du sagst, ich will
nicht speichern, aber in Ordnung, lass ich mir gefallen, so, jetzt upgraden wir, beruflich
Level 3, also, richtig High IQ Modus jetzt aktiviert, Business Class, jetzt wird es heikel,
jetzt wird es heikel, ja, hier, Cisco Internet Professional, nein, wie heißt das Ding, Certified
Cisco Internet Engineer, ne, wie heißt das, wie heißt das Oberste von Cisco, Network
Professional, ne, CCNA ist das Unterste, CCNA ist das Unterste, das ist Associate, das
meine ich nicht, gut, also, Prege, Prege, sonst ist die Kündigung direkt raus, wenn
ich das jetzt verkacke, auf geht's, Teilprüfung starten, Level 3 beruflich, übrigens wisst
ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist, was diesen Test schon instant komplett useless macht, man
kann cheaten nebenbei, niemand guckt zu, ich könnte einfach einen Tap aufmachen und nach
der richtigen Antwort suchen, jetzt starten, okay, Ubuntu, nein, nein, nein, sorry Leute,
wir wissen, ihr wisst genauso gut wie ich, dass das nicht Ubuntu heißt, sondern, sondern
Chubantu, das verstörendste Video war ja immer noch mal auf YouTube, wo wir danach
geguckt haben, wie das richtig heißt, da gab es ein Video von Nelson Mandela, der dann
sagt Ubuntu, und irgendjemand hat dann das Ubuntu Logo dazu gemacht, bloß mit dem Unterschied,
Nelson Mandela hatte mit Ubuntu überhaupt gar nichts zu tun, das ist halt ein ganz normales
südafrikanisches Wort, also Ubuntu ist eine Distribution des Betriebssystems Linux, jawoll,
weiter, oh jetzt wird's aber kompliziert, also Herr Meyer ist Administrator in seiner
Firma und stellt fest, dass es für das auf allen Firmen-PCs laufende Betriebssystem
Windows 7 keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt, ja erstmal direkt Kündigung schreiben, er
bespricht dieses Sicherheitsproblem mit seiner Chefin und er hält von ihr den Auftrag auf
allen Rechnern in der Firma ein neues Betriebssystem zu installieren, seine Chefin möchte, dass
das neue Betriebssystem Open Source ist, das halte ich für ein Gerücht, das halte ich
aber für ein Gerücht, dass das eine Anforderung ist, die von der Chefin kommt, da habe ich
mal eine Zweifel, dass das irgendein Chef bzw. Chefin sagen würde, seine Chefin möchte,
dass das neue Betriebssystem Open Source ist, für welches wird er sich entscheiden, Android
logisch oder, übrigens in Chat, wir wissen alle, es heißt nicht Linux, korrekt, der Chat
hat's wieder, I'd like to interject for a moment, was wir nämlich unter Linux verstehen,
ist er in Wirklichkeit eigentlich GNU slash Linux, lasst es mal nicht Richard Stelman,
wie spricht man den Typen überhaupt aus, Richard Stelman sehen, dass da einfach nur
Linux steht, es ist GNU slash Linux, spricht man das überhaupt GNU aus oder muss man das
GNU oder so aussprechen, GNU plus Linux, okay, Linux, ihr könnt doch Android nehmen,
wobei Android mit Open Source jetzt alles so weit her ist, weiter, im Büro von Frau Meier
ist das Netzwerk ausgefallen, ob LAN oder WLAN, nichts funktioniert mehr, sie fragt
sich, ob sie übergangsweise den persönlichen Hotspot ihres privaten Handys aktivieren
sollte und über die LTE-Verbindung ihres Handys, ihrem Dienstlaptop wieder mit dem
Internet zu verbinden, ist das sicher, okay, was sagen sie dazu, nein, bei einem Hackerangriff
wäre sowohl ihre privaten als auch ihre geschäftlichen Daten gefilmt, hä, ja, der Hotspot ist sicher,
obwohl ihre privaten als auch ihre geschäftlichen Daten sind bei einem Hackerangriff nicht den
Gefahr, hä, also C, also ich meine, die wollen wahrscheinlich A wissen, aber also ich meine,
wenn ihr den privaten Hotspot verwendet, dann ist ja nicht irgendwie die privaten Daten
ihres Handys in Gefahr, sondern im Zweifelsfall halt, was auch immer sie sich da einfängt
auf ihrem Laptop, also im Handy wird wahrscheinlich nichts passieren, aber wahrscheinlich wollen
sie das wissen, was aber wenig Sinn ergibt, ja, das ist zu high IQ der Fragensteller gewesen,
welche Vorteile haben Unternehmen, die auf das Betriebssystem Linux haben, ich finde
das gut, sehr viele Linux bezogene Fragen, sehr nice, nicht wie der ganze Windows Excel,
der kackt da immer, ordentliche Fragen, Linux ist kostenfrei, das Unternehmen spart Geld,
das wollen sie wahrscheinlich hören, ist aber falsch, das kommt ganz drauf an, was
für ein Linux, wenn man in Red Hat ein richtig echtes Red Hat betreiben will, also auch
mit offiziellen Update-Servern und sonst was, da braucht man eine Subscription und das kostet
Geld, du kannst ein Red Hat gar nicht wirklich betreiben, ein offizielles Red Hat gar nicht
wirklich großartig, also nicht gescheit betreiben, ohne Geld zu bezahlen, Linux ist weniger anfällig
für Angriffe mit Well-Ware, das Unternehmen ist somit geschützter, ok, ja, wollen sie
wahrscheinlich auch hören, es gibt Linux mehr Programme als für Mac und Windows, vor allem
Unternehmen in der kreativen Branche profitieren, nein, das kann es nicht sein, aber wir sind
uns ja einig, dieses Jahr ist das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, oder Chet, jetzt ist es soweit,
ja, gut, seht ihr auch so, ja, es ist für unerfahrene AnwenderInnen sehr einfach, Hardware
bei Linux zu installieren, AdministratorInnen können das im Grunde MitarbeiterInnen überlassen,
das ist so ein schöner Fall von, es macht sich immer lesbarer, da einen Doppelpunkt
Innen hinten dran zu schreiben, ich meine, man weiß ja auch sowas gemeint ist, es ist
für, ok, es ist für Unerfahrene sehr einfach, Hardware, nein, ist es nicht, je nachdem,
so ist es, aber Hardware installieren können, AdministratorInnen auf jeden Fall nicht dem
Anwender überlassen, auch nicht unter Windows, weil ein Anwender schraubt bestimmt nicht
seinen Desktop in der Firma auf, baut da irgendwie eine neue Netzwerkkarte ein und
macht wieder zu, die haben schon Probleme, den USB-Stick richtig rum einzuklingeln, also
Vorteile, also, ne, dann muss das weg, gibt es überhaupt AdministratorInnen, ja, gibt
es, wir haben sogar welche bei mir auf der Arbeit, also, mir fallen direkt aus dem Kopf
drei Stück aus ganz unterschiedlichen Bereichen ein, wir haben eine bei, ok, iOS-Anwendungsentwicklung
haben wir jede Menge, Zeit, scheiß drauf, iOS-Anwendungsentwicklung haben wir jede Menge,
aber das zählt nicht, Windows Active Directory-AdministratorInnen fällt mir eine ein, Datenbank-Admin fällt
mir eine ein und Software-Tests und Entwicklung fällt mir eine ein, also, wir haben da durchaus
einige, so, weiter, Herr Gradmeier ist der IT-Sicherheitsbeauftragte in seiner Firma,
er soll für die Büros einen Sprachassistenten anschaffen, er findet ein Gerät, das alle
Anfragen in den USA speichert, ich mein, besser als in Russland oder besser als in China
und eins, das alle Anfragen in Irland speichert, welches ist sicher, was, welches ist sichert,
das sollte er eigentlich wissen als Sicherheitsbeauftragte, oder, warum müssen wir ihm das sagen, das
Gerät, das alle Anfragen in Irland speichert, ja, das ist, das ist richtig, letztendlich
ist das Beste, was man an der Stelle aber machen kann, sich nicht darauf zu verlassen,
wo der ganze Mist gespeichert wird und dass es in die EU ist und sich auch, ja, alle dran
halten und sowas, weil im Zweifelsfall ist das eh alles Scheiß, Schall und Rauch, es
ist wichtig, dass du den Kram am besten verschlüsselt ablegst, weil dann kann auch keiner was damit
Unfug treiben, so, weiter, trage das fehlende Wort ein, hat man auf einem Rechner keine
Rechte, Programme selbst zu installieren, kann man auf Versionen von Programmen zurückgreifen,
Lokale, oder, was wollen die, ah, sie erfordern keine Installation, oh, wie nennt man das
nochmal, portable, ne, portable, ich glaube, ihr habt das richtig geschrieben, Streamer
Read Chat, ich musste das nur verschleiern, als ich den Chat gelesen hab, so, weiter,
tragen sie die fehlende Wörter ein, möchte man unterwegs mit dem Laptop ins Internet
gehen und soll dabei das Tablet oder das Smartphone die Rolle des Routers übernehmen, so muss
man in den Einstellungen ein, eh, Hotspot, Hotspot einrichten, das haben die uns doch
vorher sogar schon gefragt, weiter, Herr Demir schon wieder, der ist aber aktiv, er hat
eine, Moment, das, Sekunde, das, das kennen wir schon, Level 3, warum ist Level 3 beruflich
die Frage für die Privatlevel 1 Oma drinne, Scamast, Alter, achso, das ist jetzt multiple
choice, das ist jetzt multiple choice, mehr Antworten, also, dieser Vollbrechner auf das
Adressbuch im Smartphone zuzukehren, sollte er der App, die brechen, nein, nein, die Wetterapp
braucht keine Kontaktdaten, so, so will ich mal, ich mein, wozu brauchste, ich mein,
das kommt auf die Wetterapp an, wenn die Wetterapp irgendwie Sachen hat wie, zu meinem Termin
heute Mittag mit dem Max, wie wird das Wetter an seinem Standort, dann ja, aber es kommt
auf die App, auf die App an, so, Teilprüfung abschließen, 100%, huge, Leute, doch keine
Abmahnung, easy, easy, easy as fuck, easy, easy as fuck, alles klar, weitere Teilprüfung
starten, Internet, jetzt wird's ernst, oder wie man Opa sagen würde, jetzt wird's haarig,
ok, trage die fehlenden Wörter ein, Web-Tools zur Verwaltung von Inhalten auf Webseiten
nennt man, was, Content-Management-Systeme, wie schreibt man Management, ich schreibe
Management immer falsch, Content-Management-Systeme, ja, weiter, Herr Müller surft im Büro mit
seinem Browser auf dem Dienst-PC, ja, was der so alles macht, was bedeutet das, Herr
Müller, Herr Müllers PC speichert keine Cookies, ja, Herr Müllers PC speichert alle Cookies
aus Erwerbekookies, ne, weiter, Videoanrufe oder Messenger-Calls belasten auf Dienstreisen
das, den Akku, ach, das Datenvolumen, meine Güte, das Klima, das Firmenkonto, ja, das
ist doch wirklich eine sehr vage Frage, ich mein, woher soll ich wissen, dass der Typ
kein WLAN hat, das Gehirn belasten die auch, ja, das ist richtig, es belastet die Leute,
wenn er öffentlich telefoniert im Zug, das Daten, wir schreiben einfach Datenvolumen,
welche Potenziale bietet der neue Mobilfunk-Standard 5G-Unternehmen und Organisationen, ähm, niedrige
Latenzzeiten für die verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation, was sind eine verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation,
in Videokonferenzen oder beim Livestreaming von Online-Produkt-Präsentationen, ok, bestimmt,
das wollen die wahrscheinlich hören, Übertragungsraten mit bis zu 10 oder sogar 20 Gigabits, ich
hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie schnell 5G ist, aber 10 Gigabit erscheint mir etwas
unrealistisch zu sein, dass man das auch, ähm, in der Praxis erreicht, ich hab keine
Ahnung, ob, ob das theoretisch damit geworben wird, dass das maximal möglich wäre, also
100 ist auf jeden Fall zu viel, hohe Latenzzeiten für die verzerrungsfreie Kommunikation, nein,
ja, weiter, Herr Meier ist Redaktionsleiter bei einem Verlag und möchte, dass seine Online-Redaktion
zukünftig ein proprietäres Content-Management, ich sag mal, ist das Absicht, dass die ihre
Antworten sich immer selbst geben, ein paar Fragen hinten dran, was meint er, Moment,
was, Moment, was, dass sein Online-Redaktion künftig ein proprietäres Content-Management-System
ist, warum möchte denn der Verlag das, dass es ein proprietäres Content-Management ist,
das ist komplett aus der Luft gegriffen, aber ok, was meint er, das CMS ist Quellaufnahme,
das CMS ist herstellergebunden, wird dann so vom Hersteller beistellt, die Einsicht, ja,
was meint er, trage die fehlenden Wörter ein, sehr paar ist die Abkürzung, Response-Page,
Response-Page oder sowas, Leute, ich zeige euch jetzt, ich zeige euch jetzt, warum dieser
Test komplett für den Arsch ist, Search-Engine-Result-Page, easy clap, agree, mit welchen Technologien
kannst du im Homeoffice oder im Büro anonymer im Netz surfen, Proxy-Server, VPN-Tunnel,
was nochmal, mit welchen Technologien kannst du im Homeoffice oder im Büro anonymer, ok,
Homeoffice und Büro, das kommt drauf an, was geploggt ist und was nicht, theoretisch können
da alle vier dazu beitragen, theoretisch können da alle vier dazu beitragen, auch, auch,
es geht anonymer, ja, es gibt auch DNS-Server, die sagen hier so nach dem Motto, wir machen
keine Aufzeichnung und sonst nichts, wahrscheinlich ist DNS aus deren Sicht falsch, streng genommen
ist DNS aber richtig bei dieser Fragestellung, welche Mobilfunk-Standard gibt es nicht 6G,
oh wir sind schon durch, mal gucken, mal gucken, was ich hab statt Result-Result-Page geschrieben,
mal gucken was er sagt, Teilprüfung abschließen, oh Leute, wir haben verkackt, wir haben verkackt,
oh tatsächlich, 5G, das macht in der Praxis im Leben keine 10 Gigabit, im Leben nicht,
ich mein das sagt vielleicht die maximale theoretisch mögliche, in der Spezifikation
oder so sagen vielleicht 10 Gigabit, aber noch ganz bestimmt nicht in der Praxis,
ja Kündigung wird schon geschrieben, ok, das haben wir falsch gemacht und DNS-Server,
wir haben es schon vermutet, aber DNS-Server ist richtig, weitere Prüfung starten, Kommunikation,
Next, welche nützlichen Funktionen haben Programme wie MetaMouse, Slack oder MS Teams für Unternehmen,
Teilen von Präsentationen, mein Headset Leute, das macht mich verrückt heute, warum geht
das immer aus zwischendurch, ganz ätzend, weiß auch nicht was da los ist, ok, Versandempfang
von Chatnachrichten, Videoanrufe oder Versand von ja, Empfang und Versand von Verschlüsse
nein, Abonnieren von, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob dieser eines dieser drei Dinger nicht auch
RSS Feeds abonnieren kann, Pop-Schutz, ich hab den Schwamm hier liegen Leute, ich hab
den Schwamm für den Pop-Schutz hier liegen, wir schneiden den dem demnächst aus, so können
Unternehmen ihren Kundenservice zum Beispiel Bestellung bei Lieferdiensten, regelmäßige
Newsletter oder Infos auch per Messenger anbieten, warum nicht, warum sollen sie das nicht,
es ist natürlich vielleicht nicht die schönste, aber bestimmt, warum nicht, nein Messenger
sind nur für privaten Gebrauch, zugesehen, vorgesehen, nur große Konzerne können diesen
Service nutzen, kleine und mittelständige Unternehmen, Schwachsinn, ja jedes Unternehmen
kann in Messenger einen Unternehmensaccount einrichten und so ihren Kundenservice, hä,
hä, was ist das für ne Bescheu, das erinnert mich an die IHK Abschlussprüfung, die wollen
wahrscheinlich C hören, aber das kommt auf den Messenger an, ich kann mir auch nen Jabber
Account installieren irgendwo, Jabber Account anlegen, kenn noch einer, Jabber Xamp, ne
nicht Xamp, ne was ist die Abkürzung von Jabber, doch Xamp oder, kenn noch jemand,
oder weiter, JellyFour du bist Politiker im, einer Fraktion im Bundestag, sie bekommst
mit, wer hat diese Fragen geschrieben, dass deine persönliche Assistentin, weil sie für
dich arbeitet in sozialen Netzwerken sexistisch beleidigt wird, Anzeige direkt, dann ist vorbei,
ich empfehle ihr, sich im Internet zurückzuhalten und keine Beiträge mehr zu veröffentlichen,
es kommt drauf an, was sie so schreibt, das kommt drauf an, ich empfehle ihr, ihre Social
Media Accounts zu löschen, ne, das will ich auf gar keinen Fall machen, ich empfehle ihr,
sich bei Organisationen wie Hate Aid oder Weißer Ring, oh Weißer, heißt das wirklich
Weißer Ring, das ist ja auch schon wieder grenzwertig, fast so schlimm wie Master Branch,
so ich empfehle ihr, wahrscheinlich wollen sie das hören, ich empfehle ihr, die Hater
persönlich anzukriegen, ja, ja, immer, immer zurückflamen, aber das ist, das meinen die
wahrscheinlich nicht, das meinen die wahrscheinlich nicht, immer zurückflamen und das beste ist,
das beste ist, zurückflamen und dann bannen, weil dann sind sie richtig abgefuckt, also
ich glaube, ich hab Erfahrung mit sowas, ne, gerade auch durch YouTube und so was, wenn
du Leute richtig abfacken willst, du antwortest denen und schreibst was auch immer und dann
bannst du sie und dann haben sie keine Möglichkeit zu antworten und das fackt die sowas von ab,
da sind die richtig stinkig danach, ich hab sogar schon E-Mails gekriegt, weil ich Leute
gebannt hab, ok, also ich empfehle ihr, meinetwegen, ich empfehle ihr, die Hater persönlich anzukriegen,
das würde ich, ganz ehrlich, ja, aber wahrscheinlich wollen sie das nicht hören, ich bitte die
gesamte Fraktion der Assistentin beizustehen und ihre Unterstützung anzukriegen, die gesamte
Fraktion ist klar, ich hänge das erstmal an die große Glocke, ja, das ist ja bescheuert,
ich stelle mich im Netz schützend vor meiner Assistentin und biete ihr Hilfe an, das kommt
auf den Einzelfall an, das wollen sie wahrscheinlich auch hören, so und ganz ehrlich, das erste
hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, was die so schreibt und was das für Hintergründe
sind, ja, wenn die auf Twitter geht und keine Ahnung, all men are trash oder irgendwie so
Zeug schreibt, na gut, dann erwartest du ja oft mal schon eine gewisse Reaktion oder
keine Ahnung, wenn sie unter, kurz gesagt, Videos auf YouTube ihr Onlyfans Profil postet
als Werbung, da muss man sich über Beleidigung auch nicht wundern, also es kommt auf den
Einzelfall an, die Zeit läuft ab, oh nein, aber wenn ich Politiker bin, müsste ich eigentlich
ignorieren, ja, okay, weiter, weiter, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal so, trag das fehlende
Wort ein, das Team von Frau Meyer plant eine Videokonferenz zur Präsentation zwei neuer,
zweier neuen Produkte, der Satz stimmt eben nicht, oder von zwei neuen Produkten oder zweier
neue Produkte, die Teilnehmenden der Videokonferenz können am Ende der Präsentation in zwei
verschiedene Chat Rooms wahrscheinlich, Chat Rooms gehen und fragen sich, was Breakout,
was soll ja ein Breakout sein, weiter, Frau Meyer bietet in ihrer Firma eine Videokonferenz
zur Präsentation, Frau Meyer ist ganz schön umtriebig, oder, Frau Meyer bietet in ihrer
Firma eine Videokonferenz zur Präsentation des neuen Geschäftsberichts, an leider sind
viele Teilnehmer krank, oh, Monka Corona, sie schlägt vor, die Präsentation mitsamt
der Beiträge aller Anwesen aufzuzeichnen, oh, DSGVO, DSGVO, wir haben irgendwo einen
DSGVO Emote, Leute, TOS, TOS, DSGVO, ganz, ganz schlimm, sie schlägt vor, die Präsentation
aufzuzeichnen und die Videodatei den kranken Teilnehmer, darf sie das, nein, ach so, da
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt, nee, Moment, Moment, ich wollte nicht B, ich
wollte C sagen, ja, wenn sie zuvor die Zustimmung aller Anwesen einholt, wahrscheinlich, die
Sache ist nur die, ich glaube, bei der DSGVO ist sich keiner so sicher, ob und wie was
genau geregelt, ich würde sagen C, der fiktive E-Mail-Provider Mailix stammt aus den USA,
der fiktive E-Mail-Provider Fastix aus Irland, welcher wäre für die NutzerInnen aus deutscher
und rechtlicher, ja ja, Fastix, haben wir jetzt ja schon öfters viel gelernt, schon
wieder Frau Müller, sendet Ihrem Kollegen Herr Meier eine vertrauliche Rechnung per
E-Mail, diese besteht auf einer End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung, was meint er, ja, da hat er Recht, der Herr
Meier ist ein guter, der hat keine Ahnung wovon er spricht, bei der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
wird zwar die E-Mail mitsamt der vertraulichen Rechnung verschlüsselt, versandt aber unverschlüsselt
im Klartext auf Zöl, tja, das kommt drauf an, normalerweise bedeutet Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
dass es unterwegs von keinem, der das abgreift, gelesen werden kann, aber war es nicht so,
dass bei D-E-Mail oder bei Postings-Mail es nicht eine Hintertür gab bei der Verschlüsselung?
Also muss es das sein.
Okay, was sind präventive Schutzmaßnahmen gegen digitale Belästigung im Internet?
Die machen sich alle wahnsinnig Gedanken über irgendwelche Hate Speech Geschichten und sowas,
oder?
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt seit 2010 auf YouTube und sonst was, und ich hab mich schon oft
mit irgendwelchen richtig saudummen Kack, was weiß ich, ultranerfing Leuten halt, ich
muss jetzt ja nicht mehr beleidigen, als es sein muss, auseinandersetzen müssen, also
mehr als wahrscheinlich 99% der Leute je in ihrem Leben machen müssen, aber so viel
Gedanken um Hate Speech mache ich mir auch nicht.
Okay, was sind präventive Schutzmaßnahmen gegen digitale Belästigung, oh nein, Time,
in sozialen Netzwerken keine persönliche Information, jawoll, in sozialen Netzwerken
keine Freundschaftsverfahren, jawoll, Kinder und Jugendliche, nein, nein, Kinder und Jugendliche,
aufklären, Beidenhase, abschließen, easy, die letzte Frage haben wir richtig beantwortet.
So, was haben wir denn falsch?
Ähm, Moment, was, was, was, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich bitte die gesamte Fraktion der Assistentin bei zu schienen ihre Unterstützung, ernsthaft,
sondern soll, weil irgend, also, vielleicht möchte die das doch gar nicht, dass das Gott
um die Welt mitkriegt, ich mein, stell dir mal vor, du bist, du bist im Internet, flamest
dich da mit Leuten, wirst vielleicht sogar noch sexistisch beleidigt, irgendwelche Leute
posten abartige Bilder und sonst was, möchte man wirklich, dass das, dass das jeder erfährt?
Okay, keine Ahnung, außerdem, was soll denn die gesamte Fraktion da machen?
Erstmal, erstmal, das zum öffentlichen Thema machen, dass jeder weiß, was im Internet das
ist, also ich mein, wenn die, wenn die sagt, so nach dem Motto, ich komm damit alleine nicht
klar, ich brauch Hilfe, ey, kann man sich jetzt alles überlegen, aber man sollte nicht
von sich aus die gesamte Fraktion, das ist doch bescheuert, wahrscheinlich ist die Fraktion
sogar selbst daran beteiligt, irgendwelche Typen in der hinteren Reihe oder so, okay,
was hab ich noch falsch gemacht, okay, was ist daran falsch, wo steht denn was richtiges,
was falsch, okay, Breakout Room, das hab ich noch nie gehört, noch nie, wirklich, keine
Ahnung, was in Breakout Room ist, Datenweltgefahren, Schutztechnik, wir machen noch eine, komm
Leute, wir machen noch eine, wir machen, wir machen noch Technologie Alltag, danach gucken
wir noch ein paar Videos, ich muss was trinken, gibt es in Deutschland einen digitalen Personalausweis?
Ja, ja, ich glaube schon, hab ich noch nie verwendet, ich glaube, den gibt's, das war
so ein Versuch, den, der sich nie durchgesetzt hat, ja doch, ich glaube, den gibt's, ich
glaube, den gibt's, weiter, was kann ein Unternehmen tun, wenn das Opfer eines Betrugs bei einem
Fake-Shop geworden ist, ja, erstmal gucken, welcher Depp da bestellt hat und wer unfähig
ist, das zu erkennen, aber okay, Polizeiverstimmungsanzeige wegen Betrugs, kann man immer machen, egal
ob es online war oder nicht, wenn du gescampt wurdest, Screenshots von der Bestellung ist
sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt, Bank benachrichtigen, ja, es ist auch sinnvoll, wenn man Geld zurückbuchen
möchte, ja, kann man alle drei sagen, Screenshot von der Bestellung machen, wenn der Shop schon
ein bisschen shady, scam-mäßig aussieht, warum nicht, ist ja auch verkehrt, alle drei,
so, welche der Maßnahmen können Bestandteile des digitalen Detox sein, was für ein Ding,
ich glaube, das ist nix für mich als 15 Stunden am Tag vom Rechnerhocker, ich weiß nicht mal,
was das sein soll, Detox heißt entgiften, also digitales Entgiften, was, was ist denn
der Unterschied zwischen dem Bahnmodus und dem Flugzeugmodus, man darf auch sagen, dass
es den Bahnmodus nicht gibt, im Bahnmodus ist es eh kein Problem, weil die Bahn ist
eh nicht da, kannst im Freien stehen bleiben, ohne alles, ok, Smartphone in den Bahnmodus
schalten, Berechtigungen deaktivieren, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was die von mir wollen,
Bahn hat keinen Empfang, in den Flugzeugmodus schalten, Benachrichtigungen deaktivieren,
ich rate jetzt mal, ich habe keinen Schimmer, was die von mir wollen, Frau Alunathan möchte
die alten Büromöbel ihrer Firma bei E-Börr verkaufen, die Firma hat aber gar keinen E-Börr
Account, sie hat zwei Möglichkeiten, sie legt einen Account für die Firma an oder sie verkauft
die Schüler über ihren privaten Account, was ist hinsichtlich des Datenschutzes sicherer,
sie sollte einen Account für ihre Firma legen, so schützt sie ihre Firma an, sie sollte
ihren Firmen einen privaten Account, naja, also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich was für die Firma
verkaufe, wie ich es immer mit einem Firmenaccount mache, ich würde das garantiert nicht immer
meinen Privataccount machen, außer ich bin super agiles Berliner Startup oder so, da
weiß man ja nie, aber wahrscheinlich will die Büromöbel da eh keiner haben, Next, was
sollte man beim Online-Banking beachten, das Zugangspasswort sollte sicher sein, aus kleinen,
großbuchstaben, Sonderzeichen und Zahlen bestehend, das stimmt nicht, das wollen die
hören, aber das stimmt nicht, das wichtigste ist, das wichtigste ist ein langes Passwort,
Länge ist deutlich wichtiger als ein großer Zeichenvorrat, es muss lang sein, man sollte
ein Zahlungsmittel einrichten, um vor dem Abheben hoher Summen durch Betrüger zu schützen,
ein Zahlungslimit, kann man auch machen, wenn es sowas gibt, warum nicht, man sollte das
Online-Banking nicht nachts nutzen, da sind die Betrüger aktiv, ja vor allem die China-Chinesen
in der anderen Zeitzone, die sind da immer ganz gefährlich nachts, so lassen wir das
mal so, aber wie gesagt, das mit dem Passwort stimmt nicht, das Passwort muss lang sein,
der nachts ist kälter als draußen, wisst ihr doch, weiter, der Herr Meier schon wieder,
arbeitet am Tag am PC, nach dem Feierabend schneidet er zu Hause am Schreibtisch Videos
für YouTube, richtig krasser Content-Creator der Herr Meier, eines Tages klagt er über
Rücken- und Kopfschmerzen, was kann er tun, um zukünftig solche Schmerzen zu verhindern,
ein Stuhl mit Armstütze anschaffen, mit Arm lehnen, das ist das allerwichtigste, aber
das steht da wahrscheinlich nicht, er sollte mit geradem Rücken und Schultern arbeiten
beziehungsweise Videos schreiben, das möchten die hören, ist jetzt, man muss vielleicht
nicht da hören, wie der letzte Penner so, aber man muss jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit
kerzen, gerade wichtig ist, dass man die Ärme ablegen kann, das ist richtig, und jetzt übrigens
wir alle rein zappen beim Herr Meier gleich, er sollte zum Ausgleich Sport treiben, zum
Beispiel, ja das ist richtig, er sollte mehr trinken, er sollte sich einen Massagestuhl
kaufen, ja das, also, das ist jetzt eine doofe Antwort, ja das kann durchaus sein, dass
es was bringt, aber pauschal würde ich das nicht so sagen, mehr trinken ist auf jeden
Fall auch sinnvoll, Chat wieder, drei massagische Happy Ends, es war klar, dass der Chat noch
mit irgendwie sowas um die Ecke kommt wieder, egal, weiter, so, Frau Meier, arbeitet jeden
Tag und am Wochenende sehr lange, nach ihrem Feierabend haben in ihrer Kleinstadt immer
alle Supermärkte zu, was kann sie tun, krass, jeden Tag und am Wochenende, die ist bestimmt
Consultant Frau Meier, sie muss Excel Dateien copypasten, sie kann während der Arbeit im
Supermarkt anrufen, frische Lebensmittel bestellen, ja das geht, sie kann frische Lebensmittel
online bestellen, nach Feierabend, Moment, äh, das geht beides, das geht auch beides,
sie kann während der Arbeit im Supermarkt, keine Ahnung ob diesen Service einen Supermarkt
anbieten, sollte ein Supermarkt diesen Service anbieten, dann geht das, ok ihr habt recht,
wenn der Punkt ist anrufen, dann ist es B, dann ist es B, Bestellung per Fax wäre auch
noch was, weiter, was bedeutet der Begriff Smart EID, keine Ahnung, dank des Smart EID
Gesetzes kann jeder Bürger innen mit einer ID, mit einer Identifikationsnummer sich in
Online-Shops einkaufen, dank des Smart EID Gesetzes kann jeder Bürger innen den Personalausweis
nach Online als Ausweis auf, ich hab keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich B, weil ich mein,
irgendwie Online-Shopping keinem mehr vorstellen, hab ich noch nie gesehen in der Richtung,
ich kauf viel online an, muss B sein, macht aber wahrscheinlich keiner, Haltprüfung
abschließen, 100%, Leute, absolut Next Level Shit hier, 5 Headings da 5 Head, weitere Prüfungsdaten,
sollen wir die anderen 2 noch schnell durchklicken, dass wir dann uns am Ende das Zertifikat
mal angucken können, wir machen das jetzt sag ich, ok Datenwelt, ich mach mir da, ich
mach jetzt da echt mal nen Witz draus, ich speichere mir das Zertifikat als PDF und
morgen schicke ich das in Teams an mein Chef, einfach mal chance vor, guck mal hier, für
die nächste Gehaltsbehandlung, ok trage die fehlenden Wörter oder die fehlenden Buchstaben
bei Nutzenunternehmen Software in einer Cloud spricht man von Software as a Service, wobei
das gar nicht mal sein muss, das stimmt ja nicht was da steht, das muss nicht zwangsläufig
sein, aber wahrscheinlich ist es Software as a Service, weiter, trage die fehlenden
Passwörter ein, npass last Nordpass sind Password Manager, Nordpass, ja die Geschichte mit NordVPN
habe ich euch ja schon zweimal erzählt, ich muss mal kurz in meine E-Mails gucken, ob
die nochmal geantwortet haben, NordVPN wollte ja, dass ich mein VPN-kritisches Video lösche,
dass sie zu einer Kooperation bereit sind, das mache ich nicht, gucken ob es was neues
gibt, Sekunde ich schau mal kurz rein, Auszahlungsvergütung, ah das lese ich natürlich immer gerne, Umfrage,
ich kriege wieder G2A Werbung, MonkaS, geh weg, ok schnell, also weiter, Herr Demir vertritt
seine Kollegin Frau Schmidt auf einem Messe stand, seiner Firma, ein Interessent meldet
sich und möchte mit der Firma Kontakt aufnehmen, leider sind Herr Demirs Visitenkarten alle,
feels Batman, Visitenkarten, das ist ja schon richtig Boomer Style oder, ok darf er die
Visitenkarte von Frau Schmidt verteilen, ja wenn Frau Schmidt der Weitergabe ihrer persönlichen
Kontaktdaten an Interessenten zugeschümmelt, ja, Herr Yilmaz meint, meine Daten sind synchronisiert
worden, was meint er, wahrscheinlich weiß er nicht wovon er spricht, deswegen können
wir das eigentlich überspringen, die Daten die er meint sind auf der internen und externen
Festplatte gleichzeitig geöffnet worden, die Daten die meint er auf dem internen und externen
auf dem gleichen Stand, wahrscheinlich meint er das, ja, wobei, also das, egal, er weiß
wie gesagt, er weiß nicht wovon er spricht, der Herr Krallmayer ist wieder am Start, sagt
zu seinem Kollegen, Verstöße gegen den Datenschutz können Unternehmen bis zu 20 Millionen Euro
Strafgeld kosten, hat er recht, keine Ahnung was in der DSGVO als Höchststrafe drin steht,
ja das wäre in der Regel sind die Bußgelder viel niedriger, ok, ja die Datenschutzbörse
kann aber von der Strafe abziehen, wenn der Datenschutzverschluss schnell beruht, wahrscheinlich
auch, nein so hoch darf die Strafe, nein es gibt kein Geld, wahrscheinlich A und B oder,
Chat was meint ihr, wahrscheinlich A und B, passt, nur A, warum ist, warum nur A, kann
ihr nicht davon absehen, ich hab keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin, warum sollen die davon
absehen, was weiß ich, ich frage jetzt, ob sie es können oder nicht, egal wir lassen
das jetzt so, Ralf bekommt nach dem Login in seinem, die haben es nicht mit richtig
deutschen Sätzen, ich meine ich schreib auch viel Mist, aber wenn das ein offizieller
Webauftritt ist, wer hat denn das geschrieben, haben sie das irgendwie über Pfeifer in Indian
Out gesourced oder was, Ralf bekommt nach dem Login in seinen Online Shop eine SMS mit
einem Code an sein Smartphone gesendet, mit dem Code soll er den Login bestätigen, er
hat die zwei Faktor Authentisierung, schreibt man das in Deutsch so, Authentisierung tatsächlich,
es müsste aber eigentlich eine Authentifizierung sein, weil der Unterschied da zwischen den
beiden ist, das eine bedeutet, ob du rein darfst, das andere bedeutet, was du dann danach
darfst, wenn du drinne bist, das ist der Unterschied zwischen Authentifizierung und Authentifizierung,
da bin ich mal gespannt, ob die das hinkriegen, wenn man da zwei, da bin ich mal gespannt,
wenn man da zwei reinschreibt, dürfen ArbeitnehmerInnen nach einer Kündigung von ihrem ArbeitgeberInnen,
von ihrem ArbeitgeberInnen, Moment, Alter, muss man Arbeitgeber ernsthaft gendern, ich
meine ArbeitnehmerInnen verstehe ich ja noch irgendwie, aber von ihrem Arbeitgeber, das
ist doch schon so ein abstraktes Ding und bezieht sich halt meistens noch nicht nur auf eine
echte Person, sondern eben halt auf das Unternehmen, das Unternehmen ist ja der Arbeitgeber und
nicht irgendwie eine Person, naja, dass ihre personenbezogenen Daten im Unternehmen gelöscht
werden, ja, ja, ich denke mal schon, ich meine die erste Antwort ist so bescheuert, das kann
eigentlich nicht sein, ja oder, ich denke, dass das passt, ich finde das geil, da sagst
du, Alter, machst du dich einmal über die Geschichte lustig, schon kommen sie im Chat
die Leute an, ja, Max, ja, ha ha, null, fick die Scheiße, was, ne, die Sache ist wie immer
nicht schwarz und weiß, aber das ist, was, das ist ja klar, das, das, so ist das halt
im Chat, das ist, wie viel ist nicht schwarz und weiß und wisst ihr warum, ich persönlich
bin ja der Meinung, die ganzen Diskussionen über gendern und nicht gendern sind komplett
heiße Luft und eigentlich komplett verschwendetes Geld, Geld auch, verschwendete Zeit. Wisst
ihr warum da so viel darüber diskutiert wird? Also ich bin der Meinung, das wird sich entweder
durchsetzen oder nicht, wenn es einen sinnvollen Mehrwert bietet und die Leute davon überzeugt
mit der Zeit. Wird sich das durchsetzen, übers Knie brechen, kann so nichts, aber wisst
ihr, wisst ihr warum da so viele Leute wahnsinnig emotional und aufgeheizt darüber diskutieren?
Das liegt einzig und allein daran, weil es ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein simples Thema
ist, wo jeder irgendeine Meinung dazu hat, die er kundtun will. Ja, das ist jetzt keine
Raketenwissenschaft, das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich überschaubares, simples Themengebiet,
wo man, wo jeder meint, was dazu sagen zu müssen. Und jeder, jeder ist da Meinung,
jeder muss sein, jeder, die anderen sagen, nein, darf auf gar keinen Fall sein. Und eigentlich
lenkt das von deutlich wichtigeren Problemen ab, die man hat, worüber sich die Leute sich
vielleicht mal Gedanken machen sollten. Ansonsten, mir ist das vollkommen egal. Ich könnte es
an manchen Stellen sehr unglücklich lesbar, gerade wenn man noch nicht einmal sich darauf
geeinigt hat, wie man es denn jetzt macht, mit Doppelpunkt, mit Unterstrichen, mit Grunes
im E-Mail, mit kleinem E-Mail, mit Sternchen auseinandergeschrieben. Wisst ihr eigentlich,
wie man Bürgermeister richtig gendert? Es ist, wenn man genau nimmt, ist es der Bürger,
also manche, die Noobs würden jetzt schreiben BürgermeisterInnen, aber in Wirklichkeit
ist es ja BürgerInnen, MeisterInnen, weil Bürger muss ja nicht ein Kerl sein. Eigentlich
wäre Bürgermeister korrekt gegendert BürgerInnen-MeisterInnen. Ja, und da wird es mir auch ein bisschen zu
abgedreht, ehrlich gesagt. So, weiter ohne noch eine Minute, fuck. GPG4Win, ArchieKripp,
Kripp und Schubach sind Programme zur Verschlüsselung und Laufwerken. Exzellent. Und? Und? 100%!
Leute, er hat zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen mit der Zahl 2 gecheckt. Easy. Easy. So, letzte
Prüfung, starten. Auf geht's. Hilmas ist wieder am Start. Finde bei Twitter einen Account
von ihm, den er nicht registriert hat. Das waren die Hater bestimmt. Mein Opa ist auf
Twitch, nice. Easy. Danke für den Prime-Sub. Den er nicht registriert hat. Offenbar hat
jemand seine Identität gestohlen. Was sollte Herr Hilmats machen? Ehrlich gesagt, ignorieren.
Wahrscheinlich ist es, ich mein, geht mal auf Twitter und such da mal nach MaxFPS. Da findest
du durchaus einige. Und who cares, ja. Okay, den Betrüger bei Twitter per Direktnachricht
anschreiben und ihn bitten, den Account zu löschen. Kann man probieren. Wird wahrscheinlich
nichts bringen, weil das Konto inaktiv ist. Anzeige bei der Polizei erstatten. Nein, das
Fake-Konto bei Twitter. Ja. An dem seiner Stelle würde ich einfach einen neuen Account erstellen.
Herr Hilmats underscore 2022 oder sowas. Frau Demir ist Systemadministratorin. Ihr Chef
meint, Antiviren-Software anzuschaffen, das wäre zu teuer und unnötig. Ist es auch?
Ist es. Was wären gute Argumente um ihren Chef? Gar nicht. Alles bloated. Der Chef hat
Recht. Okay, gute Antiviren-Software findet Schadsoftware und kann sie unschädlich machen.
Ja, aber der Winner aus Defender macht das auch schon. Worüber man sich unter, genau,
real Hilmats macht, das ist ein Twitter-Account. Also, worüber man sich vielleicht unterhalten
kann, ist für den Fileserver sowas anzuschaffen oder sowas. Also, gehen wir mal davon aus,
wie sie wollen das wirklich. Sie wollen das wirklich an. Okay. Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht haben sie auch ein Krypto-Miner mit dabei, wie Norton Antivirus neuerdings
und Avira auch. Gute Antiviren-Software kann Phishing-Vorfälle verhindern. Kommt auf den
Phishing-Versuch an. Möglich, ja. Gute Antiviren-Software spart Kosten, die nach einem für Hacker
erfolgreichen Angriff mit Schadsoftware entstehen. Kann auch sein. Gute Antiviren-Software schützt
das gesamte Firmennetzwerk. Nein, das ist Schwachsinn. Gute Antiviren-Software installiert
Sicherheitsupdates für alle installierten Programme. Nein, das ist auch Schwachsinn.
Gute Antiviren-Software installiert Sicherheitsupdates für den Router und Schütten. Nein,
das ist auch Schwachsinn. Also, ich würde es jetzt einfach mal so lassen. So, weiter. Frau
Meyer ist schon wieder am Start. Der Herr Demir und die Frau Meyer, die haben echt was zu tun. Ist Frau
Meyer nicht auch die, die montags bis freitags und samstags und sonntags arbeiten,
deswegen nicht in den Supermarkt gehen kann? Jetzt ergibt das auch alles Sinn. Also, sie fragt ihren
Kollegen Herr Demir, ob sie auf einen Link klicken sollte, den sie per E-Mail vermeintlich von der
Deutschen Bank zugesendet bekommen hat. Ja, wahrscheinlich Deutsche Bank echt at indiamail.cc oder sowas.
Denen sie per E-Mail vermeintlich von der Deutschen Bank. Angeblich müsse das Geschäftskontakt auf
grund einer Unregelmäßigkeit überprüferter Absender ist. Kundenbetrug, Deutsche Bank,
Kontoprüfung 654d.com. Klingt äußerst vertrauenserweckend. Was solltet ihr anklicken?
Klicke nicht auf den Link. So. TheRealDeutscheBank.ru Die folgenden Wörter ein. Ein bezeichnet einen
Teil einer Software, der es hackern ermöglicht, Sicherheitseinschränkungen zu umgehen und Zugriff
zu Systemen zu bekommen. Ein Exploit? Oder? Oder ein, ein, ein. Was wollen die denn da wissen?
Nee. Ein. Keylogger? Oyana? Backdome. Ein Teil
einer Software. Der Gerät. Also ich hätte, ich hätte aus dem Bauchhaus gesagt exploit.
Wobei er exploit eigentlich nicht ganz korrekt ist. Exploit ist ja quasi das Ausnutzen einer
sich. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die VW wissen wollen. Ein exploit ist tatsächlich nicht Teil
einer Software. Das ist richtig. Eigentlich ist das Ausnutzen einer sicher. Kann man das
Sicherheitslücke reinschreiben? Nee. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Ein Backdoor?
Ein Backdoor? Bezeichnet einen Teil, aber das ist doch kein Teil einer. Ich habe. Nein,
ich bleibe jetzt bei exploit. Egal. Mo schon wieder veröffentlicht seinen kompletten Lebenslauf
mitsamt Bewerbungsfotos, E-Mails, Adresse, Arbeiten auf allen Social Media, Facebook,
LinkedIn, Xing und so weiter. Er hofft so auf Jobangebote. Warum ist das keine gute Idee?
Er könnte Opa von Doxid. Wer hat diese Texte geschrieben? Die haben das wirklich nach Indien
Pfeiffer über Pfeiffer nach Indien outsourced. Er könnte Opa von Doxing werden. Na ja. Nee,
könnte er nicht. Er hat sich selber gedoxt. Er hat alles hochgeladen. Er muss gar nicht
mehr gedoxt werden. Er könnte mehr Spam per E-Mail bekommen. Mit Sicherheit. Er könnte
Opfer von Social Media Management werden. Er könnte Opfer von Social Media Management werden.
Von was? Hä? Das könnte wahrscheinlich auch passen. Wobei. Wahrscheinlich. Ich habe keine
Ahnung. Die wollen bestimmt A und B hören. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit kein Plastischimmer,
was da die richtige Antwort ist. Weiter. Sollte Administratorinnen Software in Unternehmen
so konfigurieren? Das ist an der Stelle auch noch falsch. Sollten Administratorinnen Software
in Unternehmen oder Administratorinnen in dem Fall Software in Unternehmen so konfigurieren,
dass diese sich automatisch aktualisieren? Ja. Nein. Sicherheitsprobe. Das werden je
nach Software nur alle paar Wochen oder paar Monate noch mal. Die Mitarbeiter. Jawoll.
Trage den fehlenden Fachbegriff ein. Herr Meyer ist CEO eines großen Konzerns und findet
plötzlich zahlreiche Accounts von sich auf Xing, die er nicht angenehm hat. In den Profilen
gibt es viele Fotos und private Daten von ihm. Offensichtlich ist er Opfer von Identitätsdiebstahl.
Wie schreibt man das? Identitätsdiebstahl. Identitätsdiebstahl geworden. Was sind Anzeichen
von phishingversuchenden E-Mails? Fragen nach Zugangsdaten? Ja. Fehlende Bilder oder
Logos? Ja. Kommt drauf an, aber ja, die tun sich oft mal schwer. Unpersönlich? Ja. Genau
so wie bei eurem Test. E-Mail des Absenders passt nicht zum angezeigten Absender-Namen.
Ja. Ja, alles. Okay. Oh. 50%! Oh Gott. Das haben wir verschätzt, ne? Okay, Frage 1,
ist schon mal falsch. Anzeige! Anzeige! Ich soll allen Ernstes Anzeige erstatten, weil
irgendjemand Yilmaz01 mit meinem Foto angelegt hat, oder was? Anzeige! Wegen einem Twitter-Profil,
das jemand anderes angelegt hat. Ja, ich hab auch sonst nichts besseres zu tun. Alter!
Alarm, Alarm. Okay, 2. Guter Anti-Viren-Softer schützt das gesamte Firmenetz. Nein? Nein?
Was ist Schwachsinn? Zeig mir mal eine gute Anti-Viren-Softer, die das gesamte Firmenetzwerk
umfassend mit ihr macht. Schwachsinn, Alter. Was ist das? Dumm, dumm. Kack. So. Hier.
Okay, hier kriegen wir keine Antwort drauf. Keine Ahnung, was Sie hier wissen wollen von
mir. Frage 8 ist falsch. Wie, fehlende Bilder und Logos nicht? Aber fehlende Bilder und
Logos kann da auch drauf hindeuten. Wenn du eine E-Mail, wenn du eine HTML-E-Mail kriegst
und da ist anstatt das deutsche Banklogo auf einmal irgendwie ein China-Chinesen-Ding
drin, dann kannst du dir denken, ah ne, da stimmt was nicht. Rootkit. Rootkit. Das,
ne, wobei, nein. Das ergibt ja auch keinen Sinn. Aber das ergibt, doch, das ergibt noch
wenig, doch, das ergibt noch mehr Sinn. Das ergibt noch mehr Sinn. Bug. Ein Bug, aber
ein Bug ermöglicht das Hacker nicht automatisch, Sicherheitseinstellungen zu umgehen. Was auch
immer. Wir haben es geschafft, Leute. Wir haben es geschafft. Nein, nein, ich will mich
nicht mal verbessern. Wo ist mein Zertifikat? Wo ist, wo ist mein Zertifikat. Kommt das
per Fax morgen an? Was? 0 von 6? Ich hab alles durch. Ach so. Ja gut, meine, meine
E-Mail. Die E-Mail, die E-Mail ist ja auch, ähm, was? Ne, Moment, Level 1? Hä? Okay,
die Seite ist auch noch broken as fuck. So, wir machen jetzt nochmal, wir machen jetzt
mal Sache. Mich interessiert mal aus, was diese Webseite besteht. Okay, schonmal nicht
Minifile, wobei, das ist hart hier. Wobei, Sourcecode? Kein Minifile, Sourcecode und nix.
Was ist denn hier los? Auf was basiert denn das Ganze? Wir machen einfach Awesome Stack,
Awesome Text Stack. Wir lassen einfach mal die Seite analysieren und uns sagen, was die,
was die, was die verwenden. Jawoll, das da. Analysiere die Seite mal und sag mir, was
die verwenden. JQuery? Wait a minute, das stimmt wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Mal kurz
warten, bis das fertig analysiert hat. Es ist erst Beta, stimmt. Underscore Lowdash,
okay, erst mal beides drinne. Backbone.js? Alter, das ist ja antik, das Ding. JQuery
UI? JQuery, Michael, JQuery, Anime.cs, MySQL, WordPress. Okay, Capture. WordPress, JQuery.
Warum verwendet es Backbone und PHP? Backbone ist ja eigentlich, ne Moment, Moment, sorry.
Backbone war so eines der ersten Client-Side-Frameworks, ne? Was ist denn das? Das ist ja antik as
fuck. Wer verwendet denn sowas? So sah der Tech Stack mal vor 10 Jahren aus. Awesomeness
37. Quality Report. Die Webseite hat wahrscheinlich 10 Jahre Entwicklung gebraucht, ja, das wird
wahrscheinlich sein. Boah, das ist aber schlecht. Nicht mal JJQuery. Ne, das ist schlecht, ja.
Also ich hätte wenigstens JJQuery erwartet. Okay, Performance ist schlecht. Best Practice
ist es aber. Performance, 41%. Sucked. Okay. Na denn? Wissen wir Bescheid, jetzt haben wir
den Internetführerschein. Code this, not that. Okay, wenn wir gerade dabei sind. Ach in React?
Ne, in React nicht. Von React habe ich keinen Plan. Rare Interview with a Perl Programmer.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt mal. Perl. Perl Hacker Mans. Oh, mein Zahnarzt schon wieder.
Okay, Moment, wo sind wir? Perl Programmer. Okay, das ist nicht lustig. Lul. Critical Update
inbound. Da kommt doch eh nichts Gescheites. Leute, ich könnte morgen ein Video über den
Internetführerschein machen, nachdem wir das jetzt ja durch haben. Wo ich ja sage,
das ist sehr fragwürdig, was da teilweise drinne gefragt wird. Big Update heißt zwei neue Skins
und drei Sachen wurden gefixt. Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde. Steam, Steam Stats. Unter 2000 sind
wir jetzt schon. Not Stonks. Es geht abwärts. Obwohl man eigentlich gar nicht für möglich
hat, das geht weiter abwärts. Und New World? New World? Was macht New World? Kackt auch
weiter ab. Exzellent. Die Abkacker sind weiter am Abkacken. Wunderbar. Es geht ab wie der
Rostische Rube. In die gleiche Richtung.
Also ganz ehrlich, das Spiel ist dadurch nicht weiter großartig nennenswert an meine
Expectations rangerückt. Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr geschockt. Das sind
der ehemalige DICE Mitarbeiter. Das hat mich nicht so geschockt im Teaser. Hat mich nicht
so geschockt, aber vielleicht taugt's ja. Alter, wo bitte spielt denn der Typ, wenn
man so eine Jacke anhaben muss beim Spielen? Ist da Minus?
Hat mich nicht so geschockt, ehrlich gesagt.
Das Spiel hat mich nicht so geschockt, aber vielleicht taugt's ja.
Was genau hat das Space Shuttle mit dem
Steam Deck zu tun? Der Zusammenhang erschließt sich mir gerade absolut überhaupt nicht. Startende
Rakete. Zumal es immer nur exciting und so on wir freuen uns, wir sind hyped, startende
Rakete, aber ansonsten hat er nichts damit zu tun.
Das Spiel hat mich nicht so geschockt, aber vielleicht taugt's ja.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie das überhaupt weiter supporten. Also ob das gut ist, wenn
es da weiter Support gibt. Erinnert sich noch jemand an Steam Machines und solche Dinge?
War das ein Steam Controller? Ja, auf jetzt komm. Ist das eine Werbung dafür?
Wir gucken uns was anderes an. Level Cap G-Bait wird mir zu sehr gerade. Zu großer G-Bait.
So was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an? Mein Zahnarzt ist wieder am Start. Der Chat sagt,
das Video wäre nicht gut. Incredible Budget Server. Wo ist er denn? Minecraft. Install
in Linux. Das sieht aus wie ein Kühlschrank. Das sieht aus wie ein Kühlschrank gerade,
auch mit der Spiegeltür. Schau das, Vassim vs. Stalker. Das ist 40 Minuten lang oder
das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an. In 24 Minuten? Nein, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an. Battlefield
has a new Contender. Was deine Kleidung über dich verrät? Ah, Lego Stels. Okay, wir schauen
mal, was uns YouTube empfiehlt. Gleich ist Badget-Time. Kein Wunder, dass das jetzt
trendet. Ein bisschen Gedanken macht es mir schon. Für mich ist diese ganze Geschichte
mit Atomkrieg und sonst was, das ist so irgendwas in grauer Vorzeit, so 1980 oder so, so nach
dem Motto, das haben wir schon lange hinter uns gelassen. Mich macht es insofern ein bisschen
Gedanken, dass jetzt öffentlich sogar schon im Fernsehen vor der Politik quasi solche
Wörter in den Mund genommen werden. Also sprich, da ist schon ein bisschen die Kacke
am Dampfen. Das macht mir schon ein bisschen Gedanken, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Natürlich
sollten wir alle hoffen, dass nichts auch nur ansatzweise in dieser Richtung passiert,
weil sonst sind wir einfach alle deadge morgen. Nicht badge, sondern deadge. Truth about web
designers. Das ist ein Risitas Video. Moment, das muss einfach. Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Du hast mir ein richtig gutes Video. Ah, schickt mal euch. Okay, Moment, nein. Okay.
Nein, ich habe es nicht. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Ah, ja.
Nein! laughs
Nein!
Ja!
你就 iba a cosas oven
Tu
Fajas
Me
chagrin
Der Chat ist voll im Text
Sekunde
Ah ja ich hab jetzt auch noch rays
Und nach einer Sitzung...
Mein
ich kann ja nicht die
Wurde sich
ich arcade
ja
in
der
Ja okay
Da habe ich schon Da habe ich Jetzt Aber schon Deutlich Bessere Gesehen
Chat Wieder Einplenden
Chat Ist Wieder Da
Das Haben wir uns schon angeguckt am sonntag den senior java script developer Den Haben wir uns schon angeguckt am sonntag das war nicht schlecht
Gibt den artikel dazu css als back-end zu verwenden das war auch ganz interessant was css und back-end
Das sind Zwei sachen die passen nicht zusammen
Das juckt mich überhaupt nicht was da abgeht
Was ist denn css das ist das das dafür sorgt dass zum Beispiel der hintergrund dieses buttons rot ist
Stylings für Websites ist das
Alter wenn Du Da die hand dazwischen hast ist aber nicht gut das schlägt dir die hand komplett durch
Die Hand dazwischen ist aber vorbei
Alter ich würde mich nicht trauen das selbst auszulösen bei mir am arm
Das gibt es als competitive frisbee Scheibe werfen gibt es als competitive sport
Echt das gibt es bei Olympia jetzt Chebatet mich der Chainlorder es gibt frisbee golf nein das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Echt das gibt es als competitive sport